it's fun to watch it
but the thing i think that makes it so
fun to watch is it looks like you're
having fun being in it yeah yeah yeah it
was it was it was really fun not for
quincy so much but for me i had a great
time i was just getting at him the
entire time i didn't even talk to him
the whole day just so it read on camera
pretty real
yeah
yeah man he was my boy you know quincy
was the first castmate i ever met
so
i really didn't talk to him much that
day his mom came to set that day and i
was like hey mom look i'm going to dog
your son in the scene
[Laughter]
so uh she was like all right do what you
have to do and you know i improv a lot
and especially when he fell on the floor
and i stepped over him
he did not like that
that was not in the script no it was not
i just had to get my iverson on you know
what i mean
i saw the moment you turned magic
johnson into ty lue is that what you're
saying yeah
exactly right okay
yeah how about that
how about bringing the different laker
dynasties together exactly fantastic so
much fun devon nixon uh of hbo's winning
time the rise of the lakers dynasty
winning time airs sunday at 9 00 pm
eastern on hbo and hbo max it's nine
episodes
for the season episode one just dropped
and the radio audience terrestrial back
here on the rich eisen show devon nixon
who plays norm nixon in winning time on
hbo here on the program so
you are reading for of
you know going into this uh project
right fully aware that you are going to
be playing your dad is that essentially
yeah yeah my buddy texted me he was like
you should read for your pop and i was
like huh okay so i immediately called my
representation i was like what is this
project because originally it was called
show time so i thought it was showtime
on showtime which is probably why it's
not called exactly that
yeah they can't go against any account
they can't have their competitors names
you're certainly not going to name it
cinemax though
you know so um yeah i i the script came
to me from a buddy called my weapons
representation and then immediately
within three days i got a response and i
went in for a pre-read got a call back
and nailed it so how were
how are you
feeling about how is your family feeling
about reading for norm nixon you know
my dad is pretty cool relaxed guy
nonscript really um and i told him i got
it he was like
cool
yeah yeah not that he wasn't happy for
me but i mean you know he won't laugh if
something's not funny you know he's just
he's just that guy so
i think internally i made him smile but
um he's the type of person if i scored
30 points in a basketball game he'll
talk about the one time i didn't get
back on defense that's just like the
competitive nature of who he is you know
he's an athlete right right exactly so
um
let's just say for instance uh scene we
just saw a clip for it to our
terrestrial radio audience a scene where
magic is
obviously coming to the lakers he's to
take your character your your dad's job
nor nixon's job uh it's a white party at
donald sterling's house which you know
at the time who knew the irony about all
that right um and and norm nixon
challenges magic to a game right uh a
hoops game and right in front of the
entire
party you start schooling them yeah and
so
do you did this this really happen this
year well okay all i mean off the books
probably you know they were competitive
might have gotten the game in but you
know it's television so everything's
okay and so they wanted to create that
drama and you know pit my dad against
him a little bit but ultimately they
figured out how to work together
it's just like anything if some if
somebody's threatening to take your spot
or your position sure you're kind of
gonna haze them a little bit my dad had
been on the team like two years prior
and he had known magic johnson won the
state championship was a phenom so it
was kind of like a big brother kind of
thing like show me what you got rook
kind of thing that's why we call call
him young buck throughout the rest of
the series because he was a young buck
coming in against with kareem and all of
these vets on the team already but we
hadn't won yet but
sure yeah and so uh i did you reach out
to your dad and
show him some of these scripts yeah i
showed him you know what's happening i
showed him um
i showed him the the white scene in
particular
and i showed him the scene where my
character is first introduced and i'm
getting the pedicure in the salon and
he's like man i'm from macon georgia i
ain't getting no pedicures man
i don't know
this is serious right this is okay okay
so i could say a little okay okay cool
let me wash my mouth but he was just
like yeah man he was i don't wear any of
that but um he
he was just like do your thing i'm i'm
rooting for you
uh i'm gonna watch the show with him
eventually but i'm
low-key kind of scared my stepmother
actually called me last night she was
like i heard you did a good job so we're
gonna watch it but i actually want to
watch it with him and see what he thinks
so man yeah that would be
yeah i mean
forget about the fact that he's your
father i would imagine any role that you
play of anybody who's living right yeah
that you'd sitting next to that person
regardless now add the fact that you
he's obviously your dad i mean that is
that would be intense and his thing was
you know i'm not a fictitious character
walking around you know so don't make me
look stupid
this is one thing you know right right
devon nixon who plays norm nixon in
winning time uh right here on the rich
eisen show i would assume you are a
laker fan
of course okay yeah born and raised in
l.a so all right so when when was the
fir what's your first laker game you
your first laker memory that you you
actually had
i remember going into the locker room
uh one time there was this uh
guy my mother knew his name was mark
scargan he worked for the lakers he
brought me down there and my dad brought
me in the laker room i just remember
seeing all these giants
back then and back then you know um the
reporters were in there where the dudes
were changing i was like what is going
on in here you know not now now at this
time i mean that definitely wouldn't
happen but i just remember seeing all
these tall people like just towering
over me i remember i met
magic i met kareem kareem's actually
been to our house a couple of times my
dad's still in contact with coop i mean
he does a show with coop and magic i
actually just recently ran into
at the all-star game in cleveland and i
was like what up magic and he was like
hey man how you doing that was pops blah
blah blah so we all have a good
relationship but
uh specifically
i just remember looking at those shorts
and i was like what is happening you
know
had to put those on i was like yo these
are some booty shorts i was picking
wedgies out my butt the whole guy you
know time i was like i might as well
work for chippendales with these things
on but in the high socks you know so
i don't know man i just i just remember
when
i realized that my dad was a celebrity
and it was when we were walking around
third street promenade because they live
in uh santa monica
and a whole bunch of people would come
up hey norm storming like shout them out
yeah and i just look at him and be like
you know these people money did you work
at amc like we going to the movie
theater so that that the concept of
celebrity didn't sit in until i actually
got older and i was born in 83 like kind
of at the height of it so i don't
remember too much about that time period
you know my time period was you know
shaq and kobe and and nick van exel nice
you know um
uh who else el elgin campbell eddie
jones eddie jones cedric ceballis all of
those people so that was my team back
then that i grew up on that is pretty
cool yeah you know the dale harris yeah
i think is that the dale harris
appearing in um
no
no
no and then space jam
is that like dale harris was the famous
lakers coach appearing in the space jam
movies back in that oh
yeah i think was in space jam too was he
i think he was yeah i saw the new one
okay yeah let's go back let's go back to
winning time
thank you for that rich i appreciate
that thank you guys so much for
watching space jam 2 or winning time uh
or uh or the current lakers right now
you know
yeah i uh i actually went to a game with
uh
some of my co-stars john c reilly and uh
and quincy and jason clark i think we
went to the
a pelicans game
oh no that was not a good game right no
that was the one that they came in a
sunday night and just waxed the floor
with them right waxed
waxed them and i was just like oh man
this is not looking this does not match
the the
show
it doesn't but you know we gotta we got
a championship in in the bubble right
era you know what i mean nobody else can
say that they're gonna do that hopefully
we don't have a bubble again yeah but of
course right yeah right um but i think
you know they just need to do some
reconstruction over there right you know
i'm no basketball expert but i don't
know something's just not yelling and we
have some crazy talent on our team i
don't i don't know what's going on you
know i'm so confused i'm just as
confused as the lakers are right they do
they it just gets worse it just seems to
be falling apart yeah and you know now
the concept that lebron should sit out
maybe the rest of the year i don't agree
with that i don't i don't think he will
he's just too competitive for that you
know and i think that you know
especially when we when we witnessed
them come back
on the the warriors that one year made
that crazy comeback right you know and
and won the nba championship i think he
has a fight in him hopefully wait what
are the chances of us making it to the
playoffs well i mean it's this is the
playing game right now right chris
what's going on
so playing so you're the nine seed right
now if the season ended today right the
clippers you play the pelicans in the
10. and then if you win you play the
loser of seven eight timberwolves
clippers
got it got it that playing thing is a
little confusing yeah it's playing
tournament yeah that's it right now
hopefully man fingers crossed for us
what would you do though if you're a gm
devon
what's the fix is it trade anthony davis
is it explorer trade options for lebron
is it i don't know russell westbrook's
got a guy i love a.d man i love him he's
just
you know when you have when you're that
tall and all the weight on those knees
because you know previous to this uh to
us filming the show i actually tore my
meniscus i was on crutches two weeks
prior to oh no really yeah because we
were training so crazy and you know i'm
38 years old so i mean obviously like
you know i had to condition myself get
into shape but i mean it's brutal
especially if you're ads height you know
what i mean or if you're as big as um
what's the name zion yeah you know
that's why they keep getting hurt
because they're so big and they're so
tall you always have knee problems all
these things so it's i don't know i just
love him i just want him to get healthy
and i just feel like the team will gel
if that happens you know
and then westbrook just i feel like has
to find his way in there because i don't
know right now i just feel like
he's trying to but it's just not
happening for him you know devon nixon
here on the rich eisenhower all right
let's get back to winning time a little
bit here before sending you into your
your good thursday here so the house the
where again
i just want to stick to what we've seen
already here
yeah we do know the way that the story
kind of goes anyway but i don't want to
spoil anything yeah so the house where
you're playing one-on-one against the
magic johnson character
where is that house here in los angeles
i believe yes he's in los angeles i
believe don't quote me but i i'm pretty
sure it was lucille ball's old mansion
damn i love lucy yeah yeah yeah
yeah
the basketball courts yeah yeah
basketball court wasn't there
no they built it they built that yeah
yeah oh what do you think desi arnaz
[Music]
you know what vivi advance had a great
outside game working on some free throws
or something right you guys didn't know
lucy had handles
her skills though you know what i mean
i mean that's pretty cool yeah it was
awesome it was awesome we had a whole
bunch of extras like you know it was it
was a scene and it just got us in it and
especially with the wardrobe you know
the costumes you know and and the set
design just really got everybody into
character and it was so easy to make
that transition back into 79 80s man and
then they built a forum inside of la
center studios
yeah when we played different teams they
picked up the floor and changed
everything inside like when we had
celtics games or clipper games it was
insane i wonder if the celtics games if
the floorboards are a dead spot
dead spots
accurate you literally playing on
parquet floors like fake parquet floors
yeah
wow
wow
what did you learn that you didn't know
watching the first episode because
everyone's been talking this week about
how much of a lunatic jerry west is
which may or may not be true might be
turned up a little bit did anything
surprise you
i knew
i knew a lot but i didn't really know
how
jerry buss acquired the team i didn't
know that
he sold missiles i didn't know any of
his previous you know backstory
to him prior to buying the lakers to be
honest yeah if jack ken cook wasn't
getting divorced yeah yeah and that
might not have ever come to fruition so
i was just like whoa this is this is
interesting you know it was very
revealing for me in some aspects yeah a
fun show great yeah i mean looking
forward to the show i'm looking at your
your credits and again i'm i'm i'm
hesitant to ask but i'll ask it anyway
because i don't know if this is true or
not were you on one episode of the fresh
prince of bel-air i was
yeah man it was really really fun um
i i played will smith's son
in a dream sequence
and
he has a flashback because he wants a
perfect house perfect wife perfect life
and i think my name was shaquille
actually
and i remember one line i say he was
like man he was like go because i was
like a dork and he hands me a basketball
and i'm like what is this dad i'm like
are you referring to the sport with
spherical objects on the opposite ends
of the court
i literally say that
and so that's really funny that that she
brought that up because it has to do
with ball so that was a really fun
episode for me to shoot and will smith
was incredible
and hopefully hope he wins the academy
award for king richard yes right and
he's incredible in that role yeah so do
you still get a residual check from that
oh yeah man tom what is it 13 cents
probably yeah
maybe i can go residual
i'm like doesn't it cost more to print
paper does
13 cents you know what uh devon you may
have missed my not one but two star
turns as male reporter on csi miami in
two different episodes
you may have missed it yeah you came a
long way rich but
i will sometimes get a check for like
eight cents
yeah and and the stamp costs 55. yeah
yeah i've gotten a check for a penny
before is that right i swear damn
straight you cash
yeah i did like a little voice over on
baby's kids and i got a check for a
penny
i was like ballin we multiplied drinks
on me
wow well and the bodyguard you were in
the bodyguard as well yeah that was a
that was a really cool part of my career
i got to meet whitney houston kevin
costner obviously and
aside from that aside from them i was
eight when i did it i didn't really even
care who they were i was just infatuated
with the snow that i saw for the first
time in lake tahoe because that's where
we filmed uh-huh when i'm about to you
know die on the boat and the boat's
about to blow up
i didn't care about anything but the
snow i was like can we get to lake tahoe
please
and my mom's like don't you know who
this is i was like don't care want to
make a snowball
i don't care
i just could not imagine if i was eight
and i saw whitney houston i know oh my
god this is gonna be one of the most
beautiful people i've ever labeled and
she was man she would sing to me in the
trailer come on and i was yeah and i was
like wow you can sing
[Laughter]
i was like wow this is sick cool thank
you life is wild man it is now you're
playing your dad on on a red hot show on
hbo and just one episode in so
congratulations thank you so much and i
look forward to seeing the way the rest
of this series plays out because it's a
ton of fun thank you just a ton of fun
uh thanks for coming on hey thank you
thank you guys
your dad was a former clipper i mean you
ever thought about jumping ship and yeah
that's all i'm saying
by the way you put do you see bro
hey man you should come on board i
talked to max and rodney and jim and all
them yeah man just saying i broke out my
norm nixon clippers jersey today you
know
on the clippers and the lakers yeah yeah
i know yeah i'm very well aware of what
you know you know more stats than me so
let me shut up
i just like the fact tj that you're
shooting your shot right now always man
yeah oh i gotta wrap the clips but like
what would you do if you actually
renounce the lakers on this program for
the clippers like what would that that
wouldn't would that go over well
yeah
i don't know rick should put me in a
tough position
he's royalty in both locker rooms
great to see you thanks for coming on
thank you guys so much devon nixon
everybody check out again uh winning
time airing sunday nights at nine
eastern on hbo and hbo max hey you
watched all the way to the end thanks
for that watch more right here